yo
boo lakehead podcast we have got the
very very legendary very very talented
oh jeez snow snow the product is here
ladies and gentlemen thank you
thank you so much welcome to the uh
podcast you've been um
killing [ __ ] during the quarantine we
were i was talking to you i was like man
your podcast is going crazy you're
independent
not as much as yours no i'm trying to
learn from you and yes
you've seen me you've it's been a long
journey between us huh yeah
um i think the first time we ever met
was at south by southwest and you had a
bit of a
grudge against me because the interview
the interview never came out
forever yeah the interview never came
out i don't know what happened [ __ ]
kev i was drunk at south by interviewing
people i think it was 2013
yeah and um and yeah i know that
i was just salty because that happened
to me with a few different people it's
way even
i told you and yeah and i was just like
yo i feel like everybody just doesn't
want
a mexican girl to [ __ ] say her [ __ ]
but no i understand
as someone who's married to a mexican
woman and who has had a child with
another mexican woman
okay i love mexican women you just don't
want to hear us talk
no i know all i do is walk into my life
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding nah
but um obviously you know you've had a
long journey and um
you know now that you're independent you
got no management
um you had a stint with like atlantic
records that was
probably less than uh fulfilling yeah
yeah what made you like just decide to
just go all in on just
fully independence and getting rid of
management and all that because even
people are independent usually have
management
yeah i um i feel like
huh where do i start i'm a very
accountable person
like if i [ __ ] up like i'll tell you and
like all you know what i mean like i
just was raised like that my dad
was a very macho like mexican man that
was just like you know my word is my
bond and all this [ __ ] so like he really
was like you're
and i was a tomboy so like he really was
like you're gonna be like that like
i don't care that you're a girl you
better you know always so i always have
been accountable so whenever
i realized um that this industry has a
lot of people that are not accountable
or like
you know whenever mistakes happen if
people just own up to them that's cool
but whenever it starts being finger
pointing and whatever when you got too
many chefs in the kitchen what happens
is
there's way more people to point the
fingers so now you start kind of getting
[ __ ] up and i think dave chappelle
said this in an interview like
it'd be feeling like people want you to
[ __ ] go crazy like you'd be like yo
like are y'all doing this on purpose
like
i can't tell what's going on so i needed
to distance myself from everything and
everyone and be like okay like let me
reset and make sure i'm not tripping
because i have fans i i do go on tour i
work my
[ __ ] ass off i get up at seven in the
morning i go to sleep at you know
midnight i'm recording or i'm vlogging
or i'm shooting videos or i'm editing or
i'm
i'm doing all these things i'm like no
way you could tell me
it's all on me you know what i mean but
i feel like people would make me feel
like it was all on me so i was like all
right bet like let's just do it and if i
take my l then i'll take my l proudly
and if i win then i'll win
and lucky for me i just valued
being happy and i'm very happy right now
so i'm how long ago
did that like officially like come into
like how long would you get out of the
atlantic situation and become fully like
indie from everything
it's gonna be two years i think like a
year and a half or something like that
i think i'm very bad with time but like
so what have you noticed like
did you notice that it wasn't like you
weren't crazy essentially yeah
yeah and well and then it took it took a
while to fire my or like to get
separate ways with my management i had
done it before with another manager that
it just kind of wasn't working
i just felt like you know
in this industry as an artist um i
understand the artists that want to be
industry plants so bad
i've seen people that are just like they
want everything for them
they're just like you know please like
pull the all these favors and i want to
feature and i want to
you know go there and and and you know
suck that guy's dick and then this guy's
digging then we're going to [ __ ] um
collab
and and i'm going to take all your fan
base and it's like i've never been that
type right so i'm like
i don't see why i need to do it that way
if i'm the type like i'll earn my fan
base one at a time like i'll drop my own
videos i'm not gonna be
begging people for features like let's
just you know so to me
um the biggest thing i feel like i
noticed was just peace of mind
was just realizing that if you're an
artist you're you're a small
business so why don't you just scale
that [ __ ] you know what i mean like
rather than having a thousand fans have
two thousand and now three thousand and
now four thousand and the same way that
if you owned a [ __ ]
tire shop or a donut shop like you're
gonna do art marketing you're gonna
[ __ ]
you know get up and work every day like
it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ] i just
i don't see why um i don't see why i
should be treated any different and when
i
when i treated it like that and i
started actually seeing money i was like
yo if i can feed my family and i can
employ my family and i could make sure
that i spend
time with my kid and my girl and my my
friends and my family like the [ __ ] that
is the dream you know like what am i
really reaching for like i want to be on
rolling stone like i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah that's why i always tell uh people
i'm like hey like you you know you could
[ __ ] buying followers you would rather
have a thousand
people following you that are actually
that will give you money
that will support whatever you're doing
than having like a hundred thousand of
just [ __ ] who are following you
for the wrong reasons yeah
oh yeah and i've seen that too like i'll
be seeing people stunned with their
numbers and it's like brother fake like
we all see it like his face
even if they're fake it's like how can
you uh have a million followers but you
put out an album and it sells like four
thousand copies like what's the point
then
or even even as simple as like you have
all these followers you have like
a hundred thousand followers but you get
like this many likes or whatever it is
like or they're all like [ __ ] russian
bots it's like uh
it's the worst waste of money i always
tell people like if you're gonna spend
money on followers spend money on like
[ __ ] that like actually translate to
real people [ __ ] with you even if
it's ten of them like you know what i'm
saying like
or even that like the type of fan base
you get by having inflated numbers like
let's say let's say
somebody goes and sees your page and
goes he has a lot of followers let me
light let me just
stop it yeah like those are like
fly-by-night followers those aren't
really the ones that are gonna like love
you for you and be with you for the
struggle and you know what i mean like
so
to me i don't know i think um just
maturity kind of has made me realize
like
i want to [ __ ] be happy like i you
know i i had a kid that
i would have to leave for two month
tours and not see him you know and it's
like as a mom you know like i was
[ __ ] crying in my hotel room like all
i wanted to do was like
be with him so it's like why would i put
myself through all that
your son's 10 right he's 10 now yeah why
would i put myself through all that [ __ ]
and not be able to spend the time i want
with him so it's like i just value life
you know what i mean we're all going to
[ __ ] die at some point we might as
well
yeah you know when it comes to
i feel like there's no shortcut to
getting
the type of following you have because
you have fans who
like are fully engaged in your life and
they're fully invested in you
as like a person so if you drop a
t-shirt or you put out a new record or
whatever like they're there you go on
tour
like a lot of people who have way more
followers than you can't tour like you
yeah why give a [ __ ] you know what i
mean i think that's the biggest thing is
like
i actually care about these human beings
like there's been times when i can put
up the ticket price or i can
you know i've had these conversations
with like industry people like why don't
you just do this or charge more for this
or whatever and i'm like bro you got to
know what type of fans i have like i
have fans that
you know single moms or kids you know
that come from
parents you know their parents are
immigrants or whatever like you can't
just be like oh
bet pay 150 now for my ticket just
because i want to just because you want
to hit a lick
yeah like no that's not that's [ __ ]
scummy and i think that's one thing that
goes a long way for people you know and
and
there's both type of artists you could
be that you can be all about the clout
and you can
be popping and that's cool if that's
what you want with your life
not knocking you at all me personally i
don't feel good about that and i
can't live a life where i just like feel
shitty about myself
well also you like physically see your
fans like you'll go you're like like you
got to see these people on tour
yeah i'm on stage and i'm like staring
at them and i'm like damn i feel bad
like nah like but there is scummy people
in this industry sure that's why there's
[ __ ] that gotta be high they
gotta stay high like you done did so
much scummy [ __ ] in your life
you gotta stay high to [ __ ] be able
to live with yourself and it's like god
damn yeah it's crazy i'm not talking
about weed by the way i'm just talking
about people that i just got
other [ __ ] yeah i've seen people
you're like damn bro like just come on i
think i think we had um
i would say this like the dark age of
music that i've ever been involved in
was like 2000 late 2016 to like 2018
was probably the worst i've ever seen
hip-hop in terms of
what the industry would support right
it'd be like
there's like literal people getting
major record deals based on
antics on instagram not based on
anything else just based on
numbers and [ __ ] yeah
and like i think we've started to kind
of get like turn the corner on that era
yeah because it was like you know the
little pumps and the six
nines and yeah and then there was you
know just
instagram pranksters getting record
deals yeah
which is like with me feeling bad for
that
i don't know i'm very mom-ish you know
so it's like
i feel bad because those people got to
live with those
with with those um like what comes with
that you feel
like a lot of there's a lot of a lot of
major label people or you know industry
people that are just like all right bet
i'm gonna take this kid and did the
they're gonna that baby was like a
perfect example i was like how did this
[ __ ] get a record deal
i feel like here's the thing though and
i might disagree with you on that only
because i feel like bad baby actually
worked hard at rapping
like i feel like she she had some good
writers you really put all right but
she initially got i feel like she
initially got her deal
i'm not i don't disrespect she had some
[ __ ] that wasn't terrible
but the delivery matters because there's
a lot of rappers that are great that are
getting written for that
card if cardi b's delivery is crazy
you're trying to get a headline out of
them no no no no no no
no no no no no you don't got to say
nothing no i'm done being honest like
cardi b
don't do me like vlad yo i just wanted
to talk to them
cardi b is one of my favorite artists i
love cardi b there's like she really
can't do no wrong in my book but like
you said
yeah like i don't give a [ __ ] if someone
writes for her yeah i don't care
because her yeah i just think the bad
baby deal initially happened
and i'm not even mad at some of the [ __ ]
she ended up putting out but she got
signed
based on just her being a meme and then
she you know she committed to
actually yeah you know the craft they're
trying to
like you know what i mean like i'm not
even mad at bad baby as much as i'm at
some other people
but like she got signed initially
because
she was a meme yeah now she ran with
that and she actually took it serious
and she still is trying to take a series
so you know
i i'm not trying to throw a shade here
but that was like an example of like she
got signed because of some
ig [ __ ] but i hit her up when when when
she got signed and i was like yo on some
real [ __ ] because i was at atlantic at
the time
and i was like on some real [ __ ] like
good [ __ ] you know because i remember
how much people were [ __ ] on her on
the internet
and i was like bro as a 15 year old girl
to get
i don't think i could have emotionally
handled some of the [ __ ] that this girl
handled
me so you got to give some kids some
props of like god damn you sat there and
took that and turned it into something
and you got an opportunity you took
that's fair run with it you know that's
fair that's fair and i think i think
that's what because um my girl was
saying something about there's this tick
talker that you know had a hard life or
whatever and then
she just killed herself and i'm just
like you know it's like you gotta
understand that these kids
end up having to deal with all this [ __ ]
and all this hey like they're not
growing up how like we did you know back
in
like with myspace or whatever it's like
it wasn't as bad as now
nowadays [ __ ] like on twitter
or you know instagram like you really
can get fun you see those comments and
you start comparing yourself to whatever
you see
yeah i can't even imagine like you know
i got a niece who is just on her phone
non-stop yeah
i i could see with my own eyes it'd be
[ __ ] with her like
yeah what what's what's popping on
instagram what is considered
pretty on instagram yeah and then
comments like these [ __ ] are
we've never had to deal with that as
kids yeah and and
i don't know i think you and i might be
close in age i'm 33.
yeah um i think the most i ever dealt
with was like
like my space and that was when i was
like 18. yeah
yeah i mean it's one of them things
where you know
society you know what i mean and it's
like now it's getting to a point where
like whether you're talking politics
hip-hop
sports [ __ ] business in general like
you know
fortune 500 companies like there's a
real responsibility of being a good
human being because we are on the same
[ __ ] moving rock
and we're about to [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
also like i'm going down because your
[ __ ] idiot ass
made some stupid ass decisions and also
like tesla
be a good person because now there's a
record
of you being a piece of [ __ ] on the
internet forever i hate people
yo okay so i don't like cancer culture
as like that much
but also i don't like the cancer cancer
culture people that are like
you shouldn't have repercussions for
what you've said you should there should
be something that you have to deal with
for being a shady person like there
should be a record there of like
bruh you've heard mad races before like
no i certain i certainly think that you
know the cancer like there's like a
with anything right there's like a
middle ground where it's like i'm i'm
kind of on the same wavelength as you
i'm like yo there's people that
literally deserve to get canceled and
then there's other [ __ ] that's like
what are we doing here yeah like come on
guys yeah
i see that [ __ ] too you know what i'm
saying it's like
i guess it's just kind of is you know
it's same thing with like the me too
[ __ ] it's like there's situations where
like yeah
this [ __ ] is great and then there's
other situations where there's people
getting called out with no proof and
then their life is ruined so it's like
there's got to be a balance and i think
with the cancel culture [ __ ] that's like
a
you know yeah there's people getting
canceled and i'm like
bro that's a stretch yeah i feel like
there's people that just sit on twitter
all day just waiting to [ __ ]
just hop on someone yeah i've even
gotten it like and you know me
for a long time i've been this mexican
wave
waving the flag my people you know and
then i'll get sometimes like chicanos
coming at me
like blah blah like over semantics you
know like something [ __ ] small and
then it's just like could never be me
i'm like [ __ ]
it could never be you this has been
almost a decade of me
doing what you now see as like a hot
point or like a [ __ ] because now it's
a buzzword
and now you want to say something and
you want to come at me like no [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] record that [ __ ] has
been
doing this for a long time and i just
feel like there is
this weird sense of entitlement with
people that are just like
like they could do it better but unless
you're actually doing it like you got to
leave room for error for people
just imagine like wanting to like
like come off like you're doing right
but you're putting the effort that you
could be putting into whatever
that is into pointing out someone else
like you said semantics really a lot of
this cancer culture [ __ ] is like
semantics it's like
are we really tripping over like yeah 12
year old tweets
yeah you know what i'm saying like like
again never like or like
a little like a one degree of like being
like you know one little fact was wrong
as opposed to like the big
picture of like bruh like this like i'm
a [ __ ] human being yeah you know what
i'm saying like i'm allowed to
yeah misspeak or yeah it's it's pretty
crazy but at the same time isn't it so
crazy that it's kind of funny like don't
you sometimes sit back like sometimes
i'll look at the internet and be like
bro
this [ __ ] is so dumb like i've literally
been in some conversations mind you
important ones win like a room and i'll
literally be sitting there i'm like i'm
not even gonna argue with this person
who thinks they're on their soapbox
right now
because i'm like what am i gonna get out
of this like we're gonna [ __ ] argue
you're just gonna get worked up
you're dumb and that's it and i think
that's i think the first couple years of
trump being president
i was like super like stressed and
engaged with people on the internet
even like some of my own cousins yeah
and then the last couple of years i'm
just like you know what
like i can't give my own personal like
peace to this [ __ ] no more yeah because
it's like what like
like the people who are over here
there's just nothing you could say to
them
yeah to make them feel any sort of
different so what do you what are you
arguing for
like yeah you know like in [ __ ] up your
mood or exactly
or it's like like like sometimes if they
look turn aroundable because sometimes
my girl will get on me too like she'll
be like why are you arguing or whatever
and i'm like okay
if there's something that's being said
that's like let me correct that
and maybe you get it but if there's just
some straight up like oh like
[ __ ] i guess write a field i was
gonna say left a field but i guess
right of field um i'm just like whatever
dude like you're not
you know but there has been a lot of
times when even someone hating on me or
something like
if i tell them well actually that's not
what it was it was this there's people
that will literally be like oh wow thank
you for defeating well you know what's
crazy is most of the time when you have
haters on the internet because i've had
this
on a much smaller scale than you could
ever because you're way bigger than me
but like someone sliding my dm's not
thinking i'll ever reply
talking some [ __ ] about something yeah
like maybe i misspoke in an interview or
whatever it is and then if i reply
they're like oh man you know what you're
cool as [ __ ] yeah man my bad bro i was
tripping like
that [ __ ] happens all the time that'd be
crazy yeah no i'm saying more like
whenever people like oh like
oh this [ __ ] white [ __ ] rapping she
don't know [ __ ] and i'm like well
i'm not white i'm a mexican you know and
then they'll be like oh well what's the
difference i'm like well
you know like a lot a lot like a lot
but you know but not if we're all human
race you know what
which way do you want to talk about this
you know you want to talk about human
race and
on a big [ __ ] rock or you want to
talk about you know how i grew up or
environment or class or what way do you
want to take this mostly i argue back
with people whenever i'm on the toilet
if i'm not
you're not getting it's a great place
for sure yeah you just opened your phone
i got time
i literally have time i literally have
time right now i'm like you know
could've had more fiber i'm going to
stay here for a little bit let's talk
about it
oh that's great so um talk to me about
your experience because
so you for people who don't know because
i think a lot of people probably assumed
you were independent this whole time
because you moved around like an
independent artist
but you were on atlantic for how many
years of my life forever
um but the thing is and this is the
thing with a lot of people because i had
somebody arguing recently like
um oh you were on a label so you can't
talk and it's like actually being
shelved on a label is
worse than being independent i promise
you no the label never did [ __ ] for you
yeah so i'm like being shelved on a
label is actually
way worse than doing it on your own
because i couldn't drop
music you know what i mean like i
couldn't upload to like something
esp's yeah it's ten dollars to upload on
tunecore i couldn't even do that so now
i'm dealing with
i could be in breach of contract i could
do it like all these different things
going on
and i'm uploading to youtube because
it's safe but you know but then
so i'm being seen as an artist but not
really
being able to drop music so you can not
move you really can't monetize what you
would like
it was bad bro i didn't have there was
times when i was broke as [ __ ]
and like literally i just i
i let the world not know that because i
was just like yo that'll be the end of
my career if i literally let people know
how bad i'm [ __ ]
doing but at the same time i had my my
you know my marriage or whatever to pay
bills or whatever
i never had i wasn't i never did no
questionable [ __ ]
because like i'm a hard worker i'll
[ __ ] work at the grocery store if i
need to like i don't give a [ __ ] you
know
um so to me i
moved how i needed a move and i gave
atlantic their
their due respect for giving me an
opportunity like i've said before i
don't
i don't say that they [ __ ] ruined my
life or anything i think part of it was
like i should have known when to leave i
i shouldn't have given it the the time i
did you know like same thing with
friends sometimes like or a relationship
like
you knew when it was time to go and you
stuck around with the hopes of [ __ ]
getting better you know or like
you were like damn like you know one
time i remember i was gonna when i wrote
this song called i don't want to leave
i was crying when i wrote that i
literally was like about to leave
atlantic and i literally named the song
i don't want to leave because i was like
i signed to this thinking that i was
going to represent for my culture and
for my family and i was going to be put
on this
platform where i could [ __ ] yeah no
not even a pedestal for me a platform
for me to be able to speak on something
that hasn't been on a large scale
nowadays nowadays you see a lot more
mexican rappers waving the flag and [ __ ]
but
back then there was none trust me like i
always tell everybody like i think you
kind of broke the
mold of where like how we look at
mexican embassies because back then
it was we just automatically went to
like thinking of like little rob
and and those guys and and um
there were some guys that were like
obviously you know super dope like
psycho realm like
cyber sales [ __ ] like that but like i
feel like in your era like you were the
first
person to come along even the record you
do at mc magic and twista
you were like snapping yeah i remember
because that's the first time i ever
heard you and i remember hitting magic
like who's this girl on this song who
could really rap yeah and we have done
that track
like a year or two before but it didn't
drop
till i started kind of picking myself up
you know what i mean so i think because
i seen somebody recently be like you
know that
chicano rap you know gay open the door
for me or whatever and i'm like look
all respected chicano rap and i and i
feel that but at the same time we're
talking about hip-hop and being mexican
and and it's like
there is sonically musically
a difference you know what i mean and
it's like it's not because
i think any less of it because it's dope
like i'll get on a feature or something
but
i just come from hip-hop you know what i
mean like it's it's kind of like if
there's like soundcloud rap right now or
some some sort of like type of music and
i'm like yo
like you know i did like nah like we got
to know the difference between sonically
like or genres or whatever the [ __ ] you
know
but um with me with that that whole
waving the flag [ __ ] i feel like i was
doing it out of the need
because i didn't see it it wasn't
because i was like i'm gonna be the one
it was just kind of like yo i don't see
it being done so let me you know i think
you were the first like you're the first
artist in a long time that
was dope that happened to be mexican as
opposed to seeing a mexican artist as a
girl like he like like when you think of
little rob
and i [ __ ] with rob that's you know what
i'm saying and he's got some [ __ ]
classics you know what i'm saying but
when i think a little rob i think of
like
yeah he's mexican and oh and you think
of him like you're like a dope rapper
first
yeah and then it's like oh [ __ ] she's
mexican i didn't i wouldn't even have
known you know what i'm saying
i i think i think it's just like i said
sonically and the
the the [ __ ] how you grew up you know i
i grew up listening to
like e40 and mac dre and too short and
biggie and pun
and like you know lauryn hill and and
the outcast and it's like
that's it's just a different and it's
like no offense you know what i mean
like i i don't
it's just different it's not the same
you feel me yeah and and for example and
i had to take the hits for that because
at the same time i would go to a a car
show and perform and the [ __ ] all the
trolls in the crowd would look at me
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
straight up you know or like you know
i've had to be in those rooms where
you know there's somebody checking me
and being like oh you're you know what i
mean like you
would you chasing other races for like
we have to deal with our
colorism and our issues and our [ __ ]
culture
you know with with um with crossing
those
those lines and [ __ ] and i've had to
teach my family my friends like yo
this is how you talk this is why that's
wrong you need to i've stopped talking
to most of my [ __ ] family for the
same reason for being
homophobic for being halfway racist for
being colorist like
when you go through all those things and
you've took in the hits for all those
things when i speak
about the experience that i've had i
also hope that people
respect where i'm coming from when i'm
like chicano rap didn't necessarily open
the door for me
um because i had to kind of open another
door for myself
you know what i mean like it just is
what it is i had to
open that hip hop door for myself i feel
like
when what do you think was the first
moment where like
people started to like respect you as an
mc
uh like on a big on a big scale because
i remember like when you were on tech's
album like that was a big deal like i
remember like a few moments where it was
like oh [ __ ] snow's like doing the thing
like
like can you remember like what that
moment like one of the one of those
first moments where where you started to
be respected
in in the hip-hop community as opposed
to like you said
i think when i did the bet cipher yeah
i think a lot of people kind of like
were like oh you know and
and i was in that room like in that big
auditorium where they did the bet cipher
i could tell you the reactions to every
other cipher were edited in
there was no reaction to ciphers until i
made that [ __ ]
line that um that jocelyn hernandez line
you know and that's when people were
like oh
[ __ ] probably mostly because because she
was down she was so she was like five
people away from me and that's a big
girl i was like holy [ __ ] i'm about to
get my ass be
over this [ __ ] line i just said but i
stand by my [ __ ] i was like i better be
able to run with these heels i didn't
that was one of the first times i wore
heels i was like [ __ ] i'm about to get
my husband
but nah she was cool and that whole
thing um
was just a moment you know i i've always
used any moment i got in a big platform
to speak up on what i see and what i
think
and it's true i it still stands true
today you know people want to talk about
narcos and capos and my plug is mexican
and my plug is this and whatever
but at the end of the day it's like are
you gonna give those props
actually to like people like or are you
just gonna use the low riders and the
cholos for the music video but like the
next time that you're homie or
somebody's rapping that's mexican
you're gonna act like they're less than
i feel like what was about a year and a
half ago nico when um
there was everybody was making the same
fake ass mexican song
it was like yj go loco and the uno dos
tres cuato
it was like everybody was making that
song over and over again
and like having like sombreros on in the
videos and [ __ ] and like
when you look up mexican rapper yg pops
up i think is like number one
like i remember i was showing my mom
because i was like oh you know i had
never googled mexican rubber and i was
like i was trying to show her like if i
pop up
and it was why gina sombrero i was like
holy [ __ ]
you know and it's like that's cool or
whatever but also
for the feature you get a puerto rican
um well would have been nice to [ __ ]
give that opportunity to a mexican
person especially
why why'd you you know why'd you had a
mexican uh um sad
what's that subway loco and that's and
that's cool but what i'm saying is like
you know
in those moments it is important to
shine light at least have them on the
remix
yeah you know it is important to shine
light on things because i do think that
their needs
and from the mexican community as well
support for
you know because when the blm thing was
happening i saw a lot of people in my
culture talking out of line and being
like you know saying some crazy [ __ ] and
i'm like
no and that's when i do go and start
arguing and be like bruh you can't be
out here representing us like that
because this is going to start a bigger
issue that like
my kids got to deal with you know
growing up it's like i would like it to
be to where when my kid is a teenager
he don't got to deal with some of the
same [ __ ] that we had to deal with
growing up
and like those color lines and like
certain things that people say and it's
like
it's a big teaching moment for everybody
and i'm really
like it sucks when you really give a
[ __ ] because you end up heartbroken most
of the time about everything like you
just be like
oh you had the perfect chance to say the
right thing to say the right thing
and then you say yeah you know it's
funny because you know i'm from phoenix
so a lot of my
uh you know promoters i work with at
clubs
are latino and a lot of the clubs i do
are like you hate arpaio
of course he's a piece of [ __ ] he's
still alive
yeah he's [ __ ] just re-ran and lost
but he actually got
pardoned by trump [ __ ] [ __ ] so he
went to jail
then got pardoned and then tried to
rerun the guy's a piece of [ __ ]
arizona just went blue though i mean
that's good but what the [ __ ]
no no ajar the arizona's such a racist
place
well you remember the sb 1070 [ __ ] like
was that eight years ago with the
you know a lot of people just kind of
banned going on tour there because of
that yeah i'm kicked out of a couple
clubs in
in arizona definitely not but i was
popping off
well not clubs they were venues but i
was popping off on stage and i think
you know there was there was just but
but there was so much like um
insensitivity towards that moment
you know in june when when george floyd
was murdered
in like with some of my homies who were
latin djs
or i'm like yo guys like i would like
literally dm dudes like
you know i got a homie named luciano
who's big on instagram
and um he's big on tick tock and [ __ ]
and he was like
kind of i didn't appreciate the way he
was
handling his approach to that online
yeah cause i'm like bro like
your entire livelihood and shout out to
him because he was like you know what
bro you're right this is a teachable
moment you know
like your entire livelihood is based on
like promoting clubs where black music
is played
exactly you know what i'm saying so like
you know like you got to empathize
yes with that you can't just like when
it's convenient have your feet in it and
then
and then when you don't like what's
going on you're like man that's when and
that's what
that that's why it does matter and i i
feel like i get real mad when people
like that was good you hit him up you
see something wrong that's your boy
that's and i dm
that's exactly and that's when you prove
that somebody is your homie because you
are hitting them
privately about a manner that you think
will in the long run
you know maybe they don't understand the
only reason i'm speaking on it publicly
is because he spoke on it publicly
exactly
and it's like and it's very important to
do that but i do feel like a lot of
people stay quiet on important issues or
like
or they do it on blast you know like you
screenshot something oh my god and you
put it to your platform it's like
you're a [ __ ] like you're straight up
hoe you know what i mean for doing that
because you could really
reach out to the person public i mean
privately and try to like teach them
about that moment or be like hey maybe
you just you know this was a slip up but
you know
um i think right now that's what's most
important and yeah we need to remember
what the [ __ ] we do
and and and even just on some
world [ __ ] like i said like we're all
human beings and like you got to be a
real shitty person
to see somebody die and be like but what
about what about this what about this
well yeah it's like bro like
like a human being died like you don't
but that
you feel me like but i don't know i got
a kid and
and i'd be explaining things to him and
he just be looking at me like
last night he literally was like so i'm
puerto rican
mexican and dominican i'm like yeah he's
like
he just sat there and i think it was
just hitting him like you know what i
mean and i guess i was hitting me too
because i'm like
i'm mexican i grew up mexican my kid has
all these cultures and like
i teach him the mexican side but i don't
know if he's necessarily learning you
know the other sides or like if he is
is your son with you for the most part
he lives with me yeah um yeah he always
has
um but his dad his dad's in his life is
a real good dad but um but he's very um
you know he's a drunk supporter and he's
he's not super like
puerto rican he's not going to teach him
how to you know make platanos or
anything
like so i'm like that's crazy to think
like our kids are gonna be raised you
know especially if they're like mixed
like or or different ethnicities like
learning all these things and that's
cool to me because
they're not gonna have so many of those
color lines especially if they grow up
just kind of like all over they're gonna
be like what you know and so you do have
to teach them
about what we've gone through just so
that they don't make the same [ __ ]
mistakes cause
you know yo what up taking a break in
into the uh the blackhead podcast here
to tell you about our sponsor odd socks
man make sure you go tap in with
oddssoxofficial.com
look i got [ __ ] odd socks on right
now you know what i'm saying got the
macho man randy savages you know
uh look they got the most comfortable
socks i ever put on my feet
not only that but they got the crazy
licenses they got the wwe
how about these scarface joints these
joints are crazy man
so scarface breaking bad um
and their odd socks basics line these
joints are so comfortable
so go to oddssocksofficial.com use the
keyword bootleg cav
save 20 at checkout plus they just drop
underwear on them
plus they just drop them slippers and
they got the mass
oddsoxofficial.com keyword bootleg cab
at checkout save 20
off [ __ ] with odd socks i think the
pandemic has uh
you know for me it's brought me closer
to my family but also you know
both of my kids are in school and they
don't ever they're not ever gone
it's like i just wanna i wish i
[ __ ] would go to school for six
hours out of the day
but they're sitting at the kitchen table
every [ __ ] day for another computer
doing school and it's like
[ __ ] yeah just like what's going on
uh yeah i mean my kid he
loves the video games and goes he does
go to his dad's house sometimes but for
the most part he is at my house and i'd
be trying to find chores for him to do
we were talking about this earlier about
how like
with your kids like we want to spoil
them because we weren't spoiled
so you want to give them everything and
you want to do everything for them but
you also don't want them to be spoiled
little brats yeah you don't
appreciate anything yeah and not even
just that but like you know a spoiled
little brat turns into a bitch-ass dude
when he grows up and i tell him all the
time i'd be like you're not going to be
a bitch-ass dude when you grow up like
i'ma let you know right now you better
know
how to you know be polite change a tire
do some [ __ ] like when you see somebody
needs help
help the person you know don't be a liar
like i told him i'm like i don't whoop
your
i've never whipped my kid's ass but then
one time when he was like
he deserved a little spank on his butt
but um i've never in my life whoop my
kid's ass but i was like if i catch you
lying or like just being like that type
of person
yeah you know those people that lie and
from the inside you could tell they're a
bad person i'm like bro
we gonna square up one day when you grow
up if i ever catch you even if i don't
like your girlfriend or
your wife in the in the future you
better treat people right you know and
he'd be just laughing and [ __ ] but i
joke with him like that so
i think he's not gonna be a [ __ ] ass
dude would you and your wife ever
try to have another baby yeah bring
another kid in i want yeah i want a kid
which is why i'm like you gonna carry it
right because i don't know yeah i was i
was wondering because
you could do adoption or you can like
you like like get the intimidation and
all that [ __ ]
there's this there's this like advanced
level where it's like
technically it would be my egg and like
so i get pregnant but then they put it
into her so then she has a baby but it's
mine
and i'm like that'd be literally that's
some pretty gangster technology but i
got to make some i got to make myself
very i would say that sounds
like i know like now you could pick the
sexier baby and [ __ ] yeah
the [ __ ] is crazy yeah it's it's cool i
mean
science man that's what i'm saying like
you get a bunch of human beings trying
to do the right thing we might do some
dope [ __ ] but we're over here fighting
each other over some dumb ass [ __ ]
we gotta get it together i was just
telling the homie you know the biggest
story i've seen on instagram for like
the last two weeks is the girl who used
the gorilla glue in her hair oh my god
and i was just like i'm so glad that
this is the biggest story because
politics are boring again yeah exactly
like like i'll i'll be forgetting we got
a new president
i don't even know what the [ __ ] going
like you know what i mean like it's so
refreshing to know that like
i don't have to see some crazy twitter
[ __ ] from trump anymore or like
it's like the the biggest [ __ ] has been
this girl [ __ ] her
yeah like it's refreshing yeah i agree
i agree it's even it's like you know
when you have like that
when you're when your relationship's
kind of traumatic at the beginning and
then it just gets kind of calm and
you're just sitting there watching tv
together and you're just like it sounds
like a personal story huh just like
i'm just like sitting there like damn
it's pretty calm now like we're not
going through all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
feels good might have to raise the toxic
level again
make it interesting help me um so for
people who are watching this
like what would be some advice you would
give them on how to
build a following the way you do is it
because you know i always tell everybody
like yo make sure if someone
hits you on the comments or dm's you
they like like engage with them like you
know they're like the little things that
matter to people you know what i mean
like what would be some advice you would
give
my advice is look man again
be a good [ __ ] person like if you're
a good person you're gonna do everything
that you're supposed to do
to connect with people because you're a
good person if you're just responding
thank you because you want them to
[ __ ] buy your [ __ ]
like you're still not a good person so
that's gonna end up being your own
personal hell of having to [ __ ] keep
up with all this [ __ ] to try to seem
like you're a nice person if you
genuinely care
you're gonna [ __ ] it's gonna be easy
to it's easy for me to
get a collage or a montage made of me
and me be like oh my god thank you so
much or respond to it or give somebody a
call if they're in the hospital it's
easy for me because
i genuinely that's who you are yeah but
it's like there is people who like do it
to fake the funk and like to try to see
him and it's like
you're going to get tired of that it's
not sustainable if you're not a good
person so i suggest
go to counseling be a good person get
over your own personal traumas
figure out why you want to be famous do
you want to do it because you want to be
famous or because you have something to
say
something to represent a story to tell
you genuinely love music
like all these things you got to figure
out why you want this and if you want
this for the right reasons you're going
to be happy
at every level of it because the moment
you make a dollar off this [ __ ] you're
like damn
you know i can't believe i'm making
money doing what i love you know
whereas if you're just like i want to be
famous
have you ever had a fan go too far like
a
because you have some crazy fans give me
like some soccer issues yeah
so you've had some actual stalkers yeah
i had
what's like the worst case of that it
was pretty scary
i had camera like because i had cameras
outside i have a gate
i had to get installed in my house
because i had already had a fan show up
then
i had a fan show up and it's like i got
weird notes and then three in the
morning you know and the fan was just
saying that like we have a baby together
and like just on some like you know
methy type [ __ ]
but he put his full name so when i
googled him i found
meth charges so i was just like all
right like i'm not dealing with someone
who's like coherent so i was a little
bit scared i did have to be like
you know what do i do they brought the
note to your house yeah there was like
yeah and like
weird items and then they came back and
then they hit me up like on facebook and
were like
um i'm gonna like i'll be back like you
know i'm still near your house and
that i always wonder that like being
like you know
obviously a female who goes on since
then by the way
fair enough but being like like someone
who goes on tour as as a woman like
there's always this
stigma as when you're a dude and you're
on tour there's like groupies
like as a female who's been on so many
tours
is there is there like that same type of
energy from the other side of like like
like
like dudes who who'll be there like and
obviously you know
you have you're married now but i just
mean in general like throughout your
career has there been like
just like like male groupies there's
there's that but then there's girls who
i feel like
and i think every lesbian can agree with
me about the fact that
girls sometimes almost take it a little
further than they should because because
they think they've got the past yeah
so i think sometimes like there has been
things where it's like you got to remind
girls like hey like you know or or even
like the whole
i get that a lot like girls being like
oh if you and your girl want you know
a three you know and i'm down yeah and
it's like
no thanks like i'm good we're normal
people like yeah
but but also because i don't carry
myself that way but you know when
when i was single like and i was even
having fun out there in the world like
i don't necessarily go after fans i'd
maybe it's a personal choice for me i
think it's too easy like i don't really
you know it's kind of like predatory a
little bit of so i don't
i'm not a fan of that but um but
definitely i i've seen
i've seen my fair share of like weird
[ __ ] but i crowdsurf a lot and stuff and
like i've also never really been
violated the only time that i did was a
girl and
she got punched in the head so god bless
her
i think it was in arizona actually might
have been arizona or new mexico it was
somewhere around there but
people's lit who's been the wildest
person that you've toured with
because you've toured with some wild
dude like ritz yeah
ritz is a maniac yeah i think that i
mean i haven't really toured with many
people like as far as like co-headlining
and stuff like that or like i haven't
opened
because with that one it was me and ritz
and jeremy that was the only time that
and we were all three kind of like level
as far as right right you guys were all
very kind of like yeah
and i that was the last time that i
actually toured like
like that you know what i mean so i
would say ritz to this day
yeah ritz is a maniac yeah he's sober
god bless him you know i mean he's sober
right now i just saw him in atlanta
he needed to get sober because he was
[ __ ] off the chain wow and that's the
thing a lot of people
you know like think you know that the
rock star thing
is just like a look and then you know
you don't have to deal with the
repercussions like no we have to deal
with that
i had i had a show that i had to that's
when i realized like
it was right before like i was gonna
like publicly come out like as an artist
and everything
and i was just going through all these
things and i [ __ ] got [ __ ] up and
that made me realize like okay
[ __ ] like come out be happy do whatever
the [ __ ] you got to do to never be in
this position again you know and that's
also when i was leaving atlantic so it
was kind of like
four things were stacked up together and
i was like
holy [ __ ] you know so i just got [ __ ]
up and that made me be
like do whatever makes you feel happy
because the
misery you're feeling in your [ __ ]
head is like
[ __ ] yeah you know that's them
life-changing decisions though um
you've been you you played me some stuff
you got some dope music on the way um
what is like you could really do
whatever you want at this point you have
your podcast that's going on that's
that you do on youtube live it's like a
stream
you do it do you do it twice a week once
a week i do it twice a week tuesdays and
thursdays
and then um i you know i vlog and i drop
like songs like once a month or whatever
maybe i think i'm going to start
dropping songs a little more often than
that but it's like doing an
album even interest like interests you
anymore is it just like you're more
just doing the single thing it does the
only reason it interests me is because
when you search me on like
dsps you really can't find anything you
know it's like you can find like some
old [ __ ] and i would like there to be
some sort of body of work
yeah because i feel like the albums pop
up first yeah so so
for that but as far as like just going
the traditional route it doesn't
seem that interesting because it's like
what's gotten me to where i am is going
non-traditional so why would i like
conform to that you know but
i don't know i i got to genuinely um
admit that i am torn like do i want to
do that do i not
maybe if i partnered it off with like
the right people or brand to like just
do that
and still be able to do my thing because
i i'll tell you like i don't ever plan
on
stopping the way i do things right now
like i like
this it's just working yeah it's crazy
too because
i feel like you getting like becoming
independent when you do it's like
perfect timing because like
not only i feel like we're in the
greatest uh era of female emcees ever
as far as just like you know back in the
day it would be like there was only room
for like one or two like dope female
rappers and
it was hard like now there's like i
can't even
name well i wouldn't say ever only
because
you go back if you go back to the brad
missy foxy brown
but but but but even then like we could
name five or six
yeah now it's like emil had a couple
records in there with jay-z but yeah
yeah yeah
um no uh yeah i agree with you it's like
now it's like it's like almost like
i've just never seen like i even as a
kid like you said like yeah the brat was
crazy funkified and little kim was
was that [ __ ] and lauren hill and the
fuji's but now it's just like there's
just so much
energy that i feel like we've never at
least
i've never witnessed as far as just like
the
totality of like the industry respecting
female artists
because it used to be like yeah you're
dope but you're like dope for a girl
who are you telling i was in that no i
know you had to take a lot of those
punches i had to take them [ __ ]
punches bro like
when i was when i was starting to rap i
literally got told by one of my peers
like
let's be honest you know are you really
because we were all selling cds like
i would sell cds on the street you feel
me like [ __ ] hard
sales right and uh we we all finished
selling cds out on the street or
whatever and then we we went and sat
down and we're eating and he's like you
know
telling me about why you know he'll be
the one to pop off out of
all of us because let's be honest no
females are really ever going to pop off
like that and i just
sat there and i and now you know that my
career has gone for working at subway
yeah
no um i did have to remind him of like
bro honestly that
affected me like that [ __ ] with my
head for years because i was just like
like do i give up on this [ __ ] like
there is only one spot like you know why
would a mexican girl be the one to
[ __ ] do this you know like it doesn't
matter that you're dope like
people will probably not care you know
and i'm glad i
kept going but um i'm so happy for where
music is right now you know i'm
happy that independent artists can drop
music however the [ __ ] they want that
there is more respect for
fast rappers because even that as well
for a long time if you rap fast
you're you'll never have a hit record
and now it's like you hear
jack harlow or you hear anybody who's
rapping a little bit faster and you're
like okay bet like there is that or now
there's female rappers and now there's
more mexicans and
latinos one of the biggest [ __ ]
genres like that's the biggest
all these things are a culmination or
like lgbt
community is now so much more accepted
and like people are literally looking
for
lgbt representation so to me it's like
it's crazy that all these things that
for
years held me back and that are so
authentically me
are now accepted you
can only imagine how happy i am
that this is the case because this is
what i wanted you know i mean other than
that i'm like
i'm good i'm not starving i'm living
pretty good
yeah like it's crazy because it lined up
perfectly because
you could do what you want now you could
like fully take advantage of that now
without having to worry about even not
even that as much as like
for example the mexican thing like i
said i did it out of the necessity
if there's no necessity any more than
bet like i'm good
to you i could just do any i literally
have no pressure
to do that because before when i would
be like mexican mexican mexican
and then the song that i wouldn't people
be like why isn't she repping or why
isn't she doing this and i'd be like
what the [ __ ] i literally did that [ __ ]
this whole time
so now i'm kind of like cool i could
ease up on
all these [ __ ] things that i'm so
angry that i want to represent
and be like i just want to be happy i
just want to live i want to make
an r b song if i [ __ ] won and whether
i can sing it or not [ __ ]
i'm gonna have a blast doing it you know
and that's it i i i feel good about it
that's dope well uh do you have anything
um you just dropped the record called
shut up
yeah and the video's out right the
video's out yeah
shut up um and i got a bunch of
different records i showed you some of
the [ __ ] i'm i definitely
i'm just having fun being able to do
whatever i want
dropping merch dropping mad merch uh
vlogging with my girlfriend
my family making music videos editing
like
i like i'm doing what i love and having
a [ __ ] okay so is your girlfriend
your girlfriend or your wife because you
got a big ass ring on your finger
and this is an engagement okay okay i
remember i gotta ask because i think
that
that thing don't look like an engagement
ring she's not beyonce but i guess yeah
is that's a [ __ ] major rock right
there that's a yeah man she
i mean she makes a check off tour so
everybody does around me so when they
they what they want to do with it if she
decided to give me a ring hey man
have you um are you like getting antsy
like not touring because i feel like
you're always kind of doing shows right
so like there hasn't been any touring
for the past year
i'm not gonna lie like if you asked me
three years ago like yo if there was
ever a time when you couldn't tour at
all what would you do
i'd literally tell you i was gonna
starve to death like i'd literally think
what's my life gonna be without that i
think i needed this to realize i'm not
like you good like you could take a
[ __ ] break like chill the [ __ ] also
kind of like makes you kind of
figure out some other [ __ ] to do yeah
well i had announced
end of 2019 that 2020 i wasn't gonna
tour
like i literally had lit my last post of
2019 or one of my last posts
was me saying you know i've consistently
toured for all these years i do think i
need to you know
take a break take a little break and
relax for a second um because it was
always my mind was always on okay i'm
home for five months
i'm going back on the road i got these
many months to do all this [ __ ] and then
bam i'm back on the road
so my i was always like that i wanted to
buy a ranch that was always my dream i
wanted to [ __ ] fix it up and do all
these things so this was a
it was a godsend to me personally i mean
obviously it's not it's not a good
situation for the world but
i just felt like at least i've been able
to be home i've been able to work on the
ranch and i'm
i'll be ready when you kind of notice
the artist that like um
like there's artists that need to be
able to hit the road or do the club
shows
and and and don't really have anything
else because their fans maybe not be
like
you know like the fact that you like
pivoted and did you know i'm gonna do a
podcast where you could subscribe on
youtube
and i'm just gonna drop music and like
not everybody can do that
not everyone's built like that i guess
not everybody's a good person or
a good personality pandemic have you
ever and you've interviewed people with
right here you know there's
[ __ ] that got to have people
telling them what to say what to do
don't do this don't look like that why
because there's people that literally
are getting coached because
deep down inside bruh you are you got
the personality of a [ __ ] piece of
piece of
paper yeah yeah like we've had so many
of those you know what i mean so it's
like
there is like like i was saying like
lately whenever i get because i get
asked a lot by independent artists like
you know give me advice and i'm like bro
real [ __ ] it it starts from your core
like
be a good person actually love this [ __ ]
like do what makes you feel happy like
do what you enjoy because then you'll
build you'll build a fan base
around the things you enjoy if you like
playing video games then do that because
then you'll have a blast doing it you
know if you like animals [ __ ] vlog
about animals like
whatever you want to do [ __ ] that you
love that weird ass like trying
that old industry plant style of doing
[ __ ] is just like
we're just doing unorganic [ __ ] that you
don't want to like like you know what
it's like
yeah so you say you have a ranch does
that mean you have animals
uh well no right now i just have three
dogs i do have a 10 horse stable but
right now we're kind of converting that
because i
i'm using it as storage for what for a
while we could have horses it's
it's definitely equestrian estate or
whatever the [ __ ]
so if you wanted horses you could run it
up yeah definitely just like right now
we just got atvs like let's
be having a blast for what like what the
[ __ ] are you going to do with the horses
they require a lot of attention yeah you
know and i'd be seeing them
honestly some of my neighbors have them
and i'm like what the [ __ ] did you buy a
[ __ ] horse for him to be all sad and
depressed right there like
i'm like as a matter of fact you should
get rid of that horse because it's
depressing me like i'm gonna build a
[ __ ]
fence like trump or something and be
like yo i'm tired of seeing your
depressed skinny ass horse
shout out to the depressed skinny-ass
horses no skinny horses
in la county boom well look i appreciate
you pulling up
thank you man we had an interesting day
there'll be an elk boys prank coming out
in a few weeks
i'm sure that people will say hey i hate
y'all by the way
so thank you for pulling up um go stream
her music go
check out her youtube what's the name of
the podcast every day well every night
nights
okay so every night nights go do that
and uh and then you might be on twitch
soon you were saying with your kid maybe
playing some video games
yeah who knows we don't know what the
[ __ ] we're doing i know i'll pop up on
your studio and we gotta work on some
music we gotta we gotta figure out some
some unorthodox ways of getting this
industry riled up because that's
that's my that's my next plan is the job
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
boom another product perfect